alors ce petit cochon maître capello va
nous en parler bonbons kamil france à ce
que vendredi dernier à rodez il a
disparu il s'est envolé en fait l'argent
que j'étais dans une nouvelle phase donc
aujourd'hui le ruthénois vous offre une
france entièrement nouvelle et vous gâte
elle contenait un quinzaine ou dont six
sont déjà connus la russie comme l'est
celui de 2001 connu deux plus deux
autres nous non plus un mot là encore un
mot inconnu des suivis de trois mois
également ignoré nous écoutons vos
questions bonjour m bonjour messieurs y
at-il eu des mètres dans la face vous
plaît il y à messieurs le verbe être je
donne sans fond au personnel
naturellement je quitte ma phrase oui
dans sept mois
quand le grand footballeur de
saint-etienne iront en finale la france
dès sportifs sera contente nice que je
suis là j'ajoute nîmes francs et vous
gagnez 5 hors de france à new york et du
sommet c'est bien parti la 2005 thibault
récent la fois heureux monsieur madame
c'est à vous
bonjour mais y at-il un verbe futur s'il
vous plaît dans cette phase il nous a
pas d'homme dans cette phrase avait un
beau futur voici 100 francs pour deux
porcelets 2002 quand les aimables
animateur de télévision seront en
vacances la plupart des téléspectateurs
seront très triste
le canevas c'est en mangeant dit seront
plus c'est tellement il est gentil et la
charmante la base la dame merci madame
2002 ensuite à vous bonjour m est ce
qu'il y à le mans seront dans la phrase
est de poser une question de notre style
enjoué hop l'heureux est ce qu'il y à là
est ce que la phrase comporte des
enfants il n'y a pas d'enfants dans
cette phase toujours donner une
conclusion est ce qu'il ya un sentiment
dans la phrase il n'est pas la même
question de sentiments des moindres
frais c'est une phrase sanction est ce
que il ya une expression de joueurs dans
la phrase il a joué
cette phrase
non monsieur 2002 toujours continue mais
vous soumettre des noms est ce que dans
votre phrase il ya un nom de ville il
n'y a pas de nom de vigne hélas dans
cette phrase de 1270 je connais les gens
disent tiens je mets dans notre phrase
je touche deux verbes il y à de verbes
dans cette phrase ajoutent 500 2300
quand les choses un fonds de france sur
l'otan vacances la tâche des maîtres
sera terminé et un de nouveaux madame et
la salle on reste en 2003 bien gens
soient bien sûr y at-il un rapport
quelconque avec notre région il n'ya
aucun rapport madame hadja région de
picardie
je m bonjour monsieur est-ce qu'il s'en
rappelle que la famille s'il vous plaît
avec la famille monsieur non
2003 les questions
yat il un
main dans la phrase il y a un nom comme
je n'ai pas bien ce jeudi un homme a
naturellement il serait pour le porcelet